[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute
Mitri einen schönen guten Abend geht
doch Norbert fußballänderspiel
Frankreich Deutschland und Sieg 2 Z ein
wer hätte das gedacht schönen guten
Abend auch von mir dann blicken wir
jetzt gemeinsam auf die Themen an diesem
Mittwoch Tod und Zerstörung in Libyen
nach der Flutkatastrophe stehen ganze
Regionen weiter unter Wasser
sind
obdachlos Schulterschluss gegen den
Westen Nordkoreas Machthaber Kim
vereinbart mit russlandspräsident Putin
eine engere
Zusammenarbeit ja mit Föller hat's
geklappt der interimchef Hauch dem
deutschen Team neues Leben ein und
gewinnt gegen vizweltmeister
Frankreich nach den verheerenden
Überschwemmungen in Libyen wird das
Ausmaß der Katastrophe nach und nach
Sicht die Verwaltung im Osten des Landes
spricht von mehr als 5000 Toten und
viele tausend Menschen werden noch
vermisst das Land geschockt und
traumatisiert hat zwar erste
internationale Hilfe erhalten aber die
politische Situation erschwert das
Katastrophenmanagement das Land ist ja
zerrissen zwei verfeindete Regierungen
kämpfen um die Macht eine international
anerkannte im Westen die andere mit Sitz
im Osten und dort nah der Hafenstadt
Derna brachen zwei Dämme ganze
Stadtteile wurden von den Wassermassen
weggespült und wegen des politischen
Konflikts wurde Infrastruktur wohl
sträflich vernachlässigt jetzt sind
allein dort 30 000 Menschen obdachlos
golini
ATI darner in ostlibien einst berühmt
für weiß getünchte Häuser und
Palmengärten jetzt sind ganze
Stadtviertel verschwunden der
Jahrhundertsturm hat zwei Dämme bersten
lassen und vier Brücken zerstört
Einwohner zählen die Infrastruktur sei
seit Jahren vernachlässigt und die
Region den Fluten regelrecht
ausgeliefert
worden wir warnten die Behörden seit
letzter Woche nein seit Jahren dass der
staudam Risse hat dass er gewartet
werden muss wir sagten es und niemand
hörte auf uns und jetzt ist ganz darna
überschwemmt hunderte Leichen liegen vor
und in den beiden Krankenhäuser in der
Stadt sie können keine Verletzten mehr
aufnehmen ganze Familien verschwand
den
HEN die Wut über die ausbleibende Hilfe
ist spürbar der Bürgermeister der
Nachbargemeinde wird
deutlich nichts funktioniert hier keine
staatlichen Dienste nichts schaut
endlich hin und tut was wir erfahren
hier ein großes
Unrecht das nichts funktioniert ist auch
die Folge von vielen Jahren Krieg und
Korruption im Land jetzt die Einwohner
Hilferufe an die ganze
Welt die Lage in darna ist extrem
tragisch der lübische Halbmond und der
Staat können das nicht alleine
bewältigen eine Region so groß wie
SachsenAnhalt wurde überflutet niemand
war vorgewarnt niemand wurde rechtzeitig
evakuiert Stunde um Stunde spült das
Meer dutzende Leichen zurück die das
Wasser mitgerissen hatte erst jetzt wird
das gewaltige Ausmaß der Katastrophe
deutlich wir wollen noch mal mit golini
atai sprechen golini was sind denn
gerade die größten Probleme im
Katastrophengebiet wir haben in der
vergangenen Nacht sehr viele
Augenzeugenberichte erhalten und diese
erzählen immer wieder über das Scheitern
der Hilfsmaßnahmen gerade in den ersten
48 Stunden Libyen das ist ein Land mit
Warlords mit Milizen ein Land der zwei
verfeindeten parallelregierungen ein
Land das Krieg und Konflikt kann aber
was dieses System was diese Regimes
nicht organisieren konnten das waren
Rettungsteams das waren Sanitäter
Krankenwagen Helikopter all das hat
gefehlt in den ersten Stunden nicht nur
das es gab nicht einmal genügend
Leichensäcke es hat nicht genügend Särge
gegeben viele Menschen werden immer noch
in Massengräbern verschartr und viele
Überlebende sind jetzt in der Stadt sie
haben nichts zu essen sie haben nicht
einmal etwas zu trinken dazu kommt noch
diese Region und ihre Einwohner sind
seit lange marginalisiert diese Stadt
Derna und die Region die gilt seit
langem ja so als ein Zentrum der
intellektuellen Rebellion gegen den
langjährigen Machthaber Gaddafi und das
hat beim jetzigen Machthaber ostlibiens
general hafter auch zu misstrauen
geführt gegenüber den Einwohnern das
erklärt auch warum die Infrastruktur in
dieser Region so ist dass kein
Wiederaufbau erfolgte und dass vor allen
Dingen die Evakuierung viel zu spät von
den Behörden angeordnet wurde vielen
Dank nach Kairo goline atai Hilfe für
die Opfer ist in diesem zerrütteten Land
äußerst schwierig aber es gibt lokale
Organisationen mit denen z.B das
Deutsche Rote Kreuz und uniceef
Zusammenarbeiten beide sind Teil des
Aktionsbündnisses Katastrophenhilfe und
wenn sie spenden wollen die IBAN
lautetde 651 400 600 100 400 600
Stichwort ztf Nothilfe Libyen Infos dann
auch auf
spenden.zf.de dort finden Sie auch die
Angaben um für die Erdbebenopfer in
Marokko zu
spenden und bislang ließ die Regierung
dort ja nur wenig internationale
Hilfslieferung ins Land jetzt soll
morgen das erste Flugzeug des Deutschen
Roten Kreuzes nach Marokko fliegen die
Schwesterorganisation roter Halbmond hat
um Unterstützung gebeten so das DRK in
den besonders schwer zerstörten
Bergdörfern ist die Not weiterhin groß
viele Zufahrtstraßen sind blockiert so
dass Hilfstransporte nur langsam
vorankommen in Marrakesch besuchte
Marokkos König Mohammed Überlebende im
Krankenhaus und spendete
Blut jetzt zum Krieg in der Ukraine auf
der annektierten Halbinsel Krim sind
durch ukrainischen Raketenbeschuss zwei
russische Kriegsschiffe beschädigt
worden
in der Hafenstadt Sevastopol geriet
dabei eine Werft in Brand 24 Menschen
seien verletzt worden so russische
Angaben Angriffe auch durch Moskau auf
den ukrainischen Hafen Ismail in der
Region Odessa sechs Zivilisten wurden
nach offiziellen Angaben
verletzt seit seinem Angriffskrieg auf
die Ukraine ist Russland mit westlichen
Sanktionen belegt und sucht Verbündete
eine Art Allianz gibt es jetzt offenbar
war mit
Nordkorea die Machthaber aus Moskau und
pungyang die trafen sich heute
1500 km nördlich der gemeinsamen Grenze
am russischen Weltraumbahnhof
worostoschni Kim Jong Un sagte Putin
dabei seine bedingungslose Unterstützung
zu und meint damit wohl auch
Waffenlieferungen an Russland Nina
niebgall ein staatsdinner zum Abschluss
dieses bis ins Detail inszenierten
Treffens endensalat mit feige und
zur Vorspeise sie stoßen an auch auf den
Sieg gegen die
Ukraine wir sind sicher dass die
russische Armee und das russische Volk
einen großen Sieg im gerechten Kampf zur
Bestrafung der bösen Mächte erringen
wird gut vier Stunden vorher Vladimir
Putin begrüßt Nordkoreas Diktator wie
einen alten
Freund schön sie zu sehen wie war die
Faht der Rundgang über den
Weltraumbahnhof
einichen Raketentechnologie interessiert
und Putin laut Experten will er Waffen
für den Krieg in der
Ukraine wir sprechen
höchstwahrscheinlich über Artillerie und
über Munition für die Artillerie die
russische Armee hat daran Bedarf und in
der Militärdoktrin Nordkoreas hat die
Artillerie schon immer einen sehr
wichtigen Platz
eingenommen erst am Wochenende
präsentierte Kim in pyang sein
Waffenarsenal an Qualität und Umfang
zweifeln allerdings viele das Land ist
abgeschottet beim Treffen mit Putin
lässt Nordkoreas Machthaber keinen
Zweifel daran an wessen Seite er
steht das möchte ich Ihnen versichern
wir werden im Kampf gegen den
Imperialismus immer an der Seite
Russlands
stehen das ist die Botschaft die von
diesem Tag ausgehen soll Russland und
Nordkorea sind nicht isoliert sie sind
Partner im Kampf gegen den Westen
zur Einordnung gehen wir nach Moskau zu
Christian sem christian war ja schon
eine öffentlichkeitswirksame
Zusammenkunft welche Tragweite könnte
dieses Treffen
haben ja beide wollen profitieren von
dieser Inszenierung Kim und Putin sind
ja beide jeweils international
weitesgehend isoliert und was sie mit
dem Treffen geschafft haben ist dass die
Weltöffentlichkeit auf einmal auf beide
wieder geblickt hat wir haben es im
Beitrag gehört das Treffen war ja mit
einem gewissen Aufwand verbunden und wir
können davon ausgehen dass deals
Vereinbarung auf ganz unterschiedlichen
Ebenen getroffen wurden und wenn wir die
Delegationen sehen mit hochrangigen
militärvertretern ja können wir davon
ausgehen dass es vor allem um das
militärische gegangen ist ob es
allerdings wirklich diesen Waffendeal
heute gegeben hat darüber wurde nichts
bekannt das werden wir möglicherweise
erst in ein paar Wochen in ein paar
Wochen oder auch nie erfahren
interessant ist dabei
zu fragen welche Rolle China dabei
spielt und was China zu so einem so
möglichen Deal sagen würde Russland
Nordkorea wollen auf jeden Fall enger
zusammenarbeiten das haben sie heute
noch mal gesagt Putin hat beim
gemeinsamen Abendessen noch mal die
langjährige Freundschaft betont und
abschließend gesagt lieber ein guter
alter Freund als zwei neue Christian
vielen Dank nach Moskau auf den
ukrainekrieg und die europäische
Solidarität ging eu-kmissionschefin von
der Lin heute auch ein bei ihrer vorerst
letzten Rede zur Lage der Europäischen
Union ihre Amtszeit endet kommendes Jahr
weswegen viele ein Signal zu ihrer
erwarteten das blieb aber aus was
aufhorchen ließ von derlin kündigte
einen härteren Kurs gegenüber China an
mehr von Florian
neuhahn einmal im Jahr hat die Chefin
der EU-Kommission hier ihren großen
Auftritt EU-Parlament es geht um die
Lage Europas und gleich im ersten Satz
um die nächsten
Wahlen in weniger als 300 Tagen werden
die Europäerinnen und Europäer in
unserer einzigartigen Demokratie zur
Wahl gehen
ob sie selbst antritt dazu kein Wort
stattdessen der stolze Blick auf Krisen
und herzensprojekte wie den Green Deal
mit dem die EU klimaneutral werden will
und an dem osola von der Lin festhält
trotz heftiger Kritik zuletzt von
Landwirten ich bin und bleibe davon
überzeugt dass Landwirtschaft und
Naturschutz zusamm gehen können beides
ist wichtig eine Rede die jedem etwas
bietet von der Lin will die Ukraine
unterstützen illegale Migration
bekämpfen und China härter angehen denn
subventionierte chinesische Elektroautos
überschwemmen Europa die EU-Kommission
prüft jetzt Zölle
einzuführen wir müssen uns gegen unfa
Praktiken wehren es passt zu ihrem
Anspruch dass Europa selbstbewusst
auftritt selbst Kritiker erkennen an
unter ursola von derlin wurde die
EU-Kommission zur Machtzentrale und sie
selbst zur wichtigsten Ansprechpartnerin
für alle Partner von au b doch bei Ihrer
nächsten Wahl stünde sie womöglich vor
einem Balanceakt und könnte für die Wahl
auf Stimmen von Rechtsaußen angewiesen
sein was heute bereits von linken
Parteien heftig kritisiert wird und so
wht ein Hauch von Wahlkampf durch das
Parlament tausende Flüchtlinge und
Migranten erreichen wieder die
italienische Mittelmeerinsel Lampedusa
innerhalb von 24 Stunden sollen mehr als
100 Bote und über 5000 Menschen auf der
Insel angekommen sein laut italienischen
Medien so viele wie nie offenbar nutzen
Schleuser in Nordafrika die aktuell
ruhige See aus um die Boote
loszuschicken jetzt zurück nach
Deutschland wo das Bundeskabinett einige
Gesetzentwürfe auf den Weg gebracht hat
so soll es ab dem neuen Jahr mehr
Bürgergeld für rund 5 Millionen Bezier
geben 563 € für einen alleinstehenden
statt 502 € wie momentan eine
Solaranlage auf dem Balkon installieren
das soll für Mieter und Wohnungsbesitzer
künftig einfacher werden und Patienten
sollen sich ab April online über die
Qualität der Krankenhäuser informieren
können welche Klinik was leistet und wie
sie personell ausgestattet ist mehr zu
all dem jetzt von Ines
Trams das Krankenhaus waldbröhl auf dem
landgelegen Oberbergischer Kreis in
Nordrheinwestfalen hier schauen sie
skeptisch auf die in Berlin plante
Klinik Rangliste da ist die Sorge ihr
Haus sei zu klein um gut abzuschneiden
reine Strukturmerkmale die vielleicht
nur auf Größe abzielen und auf Menge
kann an der Stelle nicht hilfreich sein
und auch kleine Krankenhäuser können
sich spezialisiert haben und können eine
hohe Fallzahl erbringen und können das
in sehr sehr guter Qualität einen Klinik
Atlas will der Bundesgesundheitsminister
rausbringen welche Klinik ist die beste
für welche Behandlung ein Online
Verzeichnis zu Leistungen und
Behandlungsqualität dann kann man sehen
wenn man einen Eingriff möchte ob das
Krankenhaus welches man anpilt in der
Region ob das überhaupt dafür die
notwendige technische und personelle
Voraussetzung hat man kann dann auch
sehen wie hoch ist eigentlich die
facharztdichte wie hoch ist die
pflegedichte wie viele Komplikationen
hat es gegeben die geplante Rangliste
Teil von Lauterbachs geplanter
krankenhausreform in Stufen sollen
Kliniken eingeteilt und entsprechend
vergütet werden Maximalversorger wie
Unikliniken an der Spitze im mittleren
Bereich regionale Fachkliniken dazu die
wohnortnahe Grundversorgung groß ist die
Sorge der Länder dass kleine Kliniken
künftig gemieden werden was wir nicht
brauchen ist eine Verunsicherung ein
Ausbluten der kleinen Häuser ich find es
auch respektlos gegenüber dem Personal
das dort arbeitet oder eine Verschiebung
nur auf größere Häuser die das dann auch
nicht mehr bewältigen können dieses
Gesetzes mugs Lauterbach kann den
klinikatlas ohne Zustimmung der Länder
umsetzen im April nächsten Jahres soll
er
kommen der Hamburger Hafen steht
wirtschaftlich ziemlich unter Druck und
das soll sich ändern die größte Rederei
der Welt MSC will als Partner einsteigen
laut Bürgermeister chencher planen die
Hansestadt und das Schweizer Unternehmen
eine strategische Zusammenarbeit Hamburg
soll 50,1% halten das Schweizer
Unternehmen MSC
49,9%. morgen Vormittag um 11 Uhr wenn
denn alles klappen sollte wird Ihr Handy
egal ob stumm gestellt oder nicht einen
schrillen Warnton erzeugen das ist nur
ein Teil des bundesweiten warntages mit
dem der Katastrophenfall simuliert und
Warnsysteme getestet werden sollen und
was da konkret auf sie zukommt und wie
Sie sich am besten verhalten dazu jetzt
Petra
Riffel beim bundesweiten Probealarm
werden verschiedene warnkanäle getestet
Sirenen Radio Fernsehen und digitale
Infoscreens mobil kommt die
Gefahrenmeldung über spezielle warnpps
aber auch als SMS mit Ton selbst wenn
das Handy stumm geschaltet ist
informiert wird über eine anstehende
Gefahr und das weitere Vorgehen
bundeseinheitlich sind zwei
Sirenensignale
festgelegt der einminütige auf und
abschwellende Heulton bedeutet Gefahr
informieren Sie
sich und dieser durchgehende Ton gibt
Entwarnung gewarnt wird meist lokal vor
beispielsweise Hochwasser Waldbrand oder
Infektionsgefahr im ernstfald gilt
außerdem weitersagen Familie und Freunde
informieren die Hitzewelle die endete
mit einem Knall Blitz und Donner gestern
Abend im Münsterland in Hessen Thüringen
Bayern und vor allem in
Rheinlandpfalz in Worms wurden die
Autofahrer von massivem Hagelschlag
überrascht die Fahrbahnen Verband
verwandelten sich in Rutschbahnen viele
Bewohner packten damit an den Hagel von
der Straße zu räumen viel Arbeit auch
für die Feuerwehren in Mainz da liefen
etliche Keller
voll so jetzt zum Sport die dfb1 kann
also doch noch gewinnen 21 gegen
Frankreich das war ja was ja echt
bemerkenswert was der hudi Föller und
sein Trainerteam in nur zwei Tagen aus
einer völlig verunsicherten Mannschaft
gemacht haben nach groß Frust wieder
große Lust zu spielen und zu kämpfen der
Sieg gestern Abend vielleicht die
Trendwende im strömenden Regen geht der
erste Dank an seine beiden c-rainer mit
simplen Mitteln hat Völler großen Erfolg
Klasse Mannschaft wie die Franzosen bra
bisschen Glück das hatten wir dann am
Ende des Spiels aber Glück hat auch nur
der tüchtige solche einfachen Sätze
zeichnen Rudi Föller aus ein Händchen
hatte auch seine Entscheidung Thomas
Müller von Anfang anzubringen gold
richtig so ein Tor zu schießen
der Drucksituation vorher das das macht
was mit den Fans das macht was mit uns
und dementsprechend erlebst du die
Emotion auch intensiver auch beim 2:0
von L s kurz vors Schluss der
Ehrentreffer von Griem da nicht mehr als
ein Schönheitsfleck Rudi Föller wechselt
jetzt wieder die Rollen muss einen
geeigneten Trainer für die heimehe
empfinden mein Wunsch wäre es natürlich
es ist der Idealfall wenn bis zur
nächsten länderspielperiode den den
neuen Bundestrainer dann vorstellen kön
dann im Idealfall direkt an die starke
Leistung von gestern Abend
an heute Abend in Berlin große Party 60
Jahre Fußball buundesliga Claudia
Neumann vor Ort vor dem Tempo drom da
dürfte doch die Stimmung bestens sein
nach dem frankreichsieg
oder tatsächlich Norbert das ist sie
auch und natürlich haben 60 Jahre
Bundesliga den ein oder anderen
Höhepunkt zu bieten den es zu feiern
gilt aber das zentrale Thema hier und
heute in allen Gesprächen in all allen
Interviews ist natürlich die Frage nach
dem neuen Bundestrainer und Rudi Föller
dem gestern mit seinem Team ja sowas wie
ein kleiner Stimmungsumschwung gelungen
ist der ist sicherheitsalber gar nicht
erst angekommen hier denn ich denke er
will so diesen Nachfragen aus dem Weg
gehen ob es nicht doch noch länger
machen möchte akiwatzke der DFB
Vizepräsident der hat sich gleich
erstmal selbst gelobt für seine Auswahl
ihn erst in die Taskforce dann als
Sportdirektor und dann als Kurzzeit
Bundestrainer zu installieren und DFB
Präsident
Bernt neendorf lässt sich überhaupt
nicht in die Karten gucken hat auch noch
keine Kontaktaufnahme zu Julian
nagelsmann bestätigt im Gegenteil er
sagt wir müssen jetzt erstmal ein Profil
erstellen danke Claudia danke nach
Berlin für diese Information dann
schauen wir mal was mit der
Profilerstellung passiert danke schön
nbert gerne wir haben noch die Zahlen V
Mittwochslotto schauen wir schnell mal
drauf 14 15 18 27 28 41 und die
Superzahl 3 weitere Gewinnzahlen und
Infos auf
lotto.zf.de und auf der ZF Textseite
557 nach Gewittern gestern ist ein
Nachschlag Spätsommer auf dem Weg dazu
gleich mehr von Katja horneffer um
21:45 gibt's das heute journal mit
Christian siers wir sind für heute durch
Morgen um 7 Uhr wieder da für sie noch
einen schönen
[Musik]
Abend
guten Abend kurz und heftig war die
gewitterpisode das ging ja gestern
Nachmittag los kräftige Gewitter sind da
von West nach Ost über uns hinweggezogen
und heute übertag gab es noch letzte
Gewitter hier im äußersten Osten am
längsten gegrummelt hat es dann noch in
Süddeutschland und so wird es auch heute
Nacht noch etwas regnen zwischen dem
Oberrhein und Niederbayern sonst ist es
häufig klar und dann bildet sich auch
mal Nebel und wenn es klar ist dann wird
es auch kalt in der Lüneburger Heide
sinken die Werte bis 4° das klingt schon
fast nach Bodenfrost milder bleibt die
Nacht in Süddeutschland bei 16 bis 11°.
morgen erwarten uns Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 18° hier an der Schlei oder
auch am Alpenrand und 23° an moselmain
und mein Donaukanal wärmer wird's am
Oberrhein mit 25°. morgen wechseln sich
Sonne und Wolken miteinander ab einzig
ganz im Süden da da kann es noch etwas
regnen auch am Freitag gibt's noch die
letzten Gewitter hier am Alpenrand dann
aber dominiert Spätsommerwetter das
Wochenende wird also schon wieder
spätsommerlich warm und wenn ihnen 22
bis 30° schon wieder zu warm sind das
sind die höchstemperaturen werden also
nur für eine kurze Zeit des Tages
erreicht guten Abend